good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm in
New Orleans you're gonna go on Friday
contain so much cute that I was worried
I might get cute overload a syndrome
that can result in the acquisition of
puppies or kittens or even in extreme
cases the creation of human beings but
fortunately I have had a cutie shot in
the last 10 years
sidenote hey this gives me no pleasure
to acknowledge but you're of course
familiar with the childhood phenomenon
of cooties
cooties is a fictitious disease said to
infect people who are generally and now
I'm quoting Wikipedia perceived as being
different or barring some kind of social
stigma not even a real disease all of
this was made worse by the fact that I
have these birthmarks which people ask
about in every single freaking video so
yes they are birthmarks I am NOT a
heroin addict I do not have some weird
kind of fetish for hickeys on the
forearm their birth marks these
birthmarks were taken by my classmates
as a sure sign that I had perceived some
kind of failed cooties inoculation that
resulted in permanent cooties infection
but that is not the worst part of the
story Hank the worst part of the story
is that for the first couple years of
elementary school due to an extremely
well-meaning teacher I believe that the
kids were not saying I had cooties but
that I had cuties essentially I believe
that in the eyes of my classmates I was
so cute that I could not be approached
without a cuties shot which of course
inevitably led to me like sauntering up
to young ladies at the monkey bars or
whatever and being like hey there have
you had your cutie shot because if so
perhaps you'd like to join me in the
sandbox and then they would scream but
Hank like Ahab and his great white whale
throughout my school years I refused to
stop pursuing popularity even after it
became obvious that popularity if I ever
got it which I wouldn't would destroy me
hey there's of course nothing wrong with
being popular but there is something
wrong with sacrificing everything that
matters to you in order to attain
popularity by the way I think that's
true when you're talking about
elementary school or YouTube or anything
else as Melville's preacher puts it in
Moby Dick woe to him whose good name is
more to him than goodness by the way
Hank in case it isn't obvious I've been
reading Moby Dick speaking of which I
have to go to the aquarium so ain't Moby
Dick is not an easy book it contains a
lot of words I don't know it frequently
runs off on tangents the structure of
the sentences is very confusing to me at
times and plus I'm not a very fast
reader three days into my vacation I've
only read about a hundred pages so it's
not easy to read Moby Dick
but it is really fun like visiting the
aquarium you get to go to sea without
puking as you know Hank I hate the idea
that when it comes to books and learning
hard is often seen as the opposite of
fun
it's strange to me that we should be so
quick to give up on a book or a math
problem when we are so willing to
grapple for centuries if necessary with
a single level of Angry Birds when I was
a student why was I so willing to work
hard much much too hard to make people
like me and so unwilling to work hard to
read great novels or comprehend the edge
lessness of the universe I don't have an
answer maybe I'll find one in comments
or here at the aquarium or maybe I'll
find an answer looking at Melville's
great white wall of whale but in the
meantime the search is a pleasure and a
difficult one as most great pleasures
are Hank I'll see you on Friday